sanders e benvenuti in un nuovissimo
video nell'ultimo video vi ho dato dei
consigli per quanto riguarda l'out fit
da indossare il primo giorno di scuola
se non avete ancora visto cliccate qui
con il video di oggi vorrei continuare a
parlare del back to school ma vorrei
focalizzarmi su make up nei capelli
come vi ho già detto nel video sugli
outfit i requisiti fondamentali per il
primo giorno di scuola sono ordine
pulizia semplicità e sobrietà
lo so è un po strano detto da me però
siamo a scuola stessa identica cosa vale
per quanto riguarda make up e capelli
perché non mi posso presentare il primo
giorno di scuola con i capelli tutti
spettinati con un nido di vespe in testa
oppure con il rossetto fluo che metto
per andare a ballare mi sembra
abbastanza ovvio
oggi vi farò vedere quelli che secondo
me sono due look 2 make up molto molto
carini e indicati per quanto riguarda
medie e liceo poi per quanto riguarda le
medie vi farò vedere due acconciature e
stessa cosa vale per il liceo quindi
avrete due make up e 4 e style
piccola parentesi sono stata una
studentessa anch'io e so benissimo che
non è facilissimo avere diciamo la cura
e l'accortezza del look del primo giorno
durante tutto l'anno per vari motivi
ritardo interrogazione eccetera eccetera
però ecco insomma non sarebbe male se
resiste un pelino impegnarvi per essere
perlomeno sempre ordinati e puliti
perché ricordatevi che il nostro look
comunque il modo in cui ci presentiamo
agli altri è un biglietto da visita
quindi è la prima cosa che gli altri
notano di noi poi ovviamente c'è la
conoscenza di una persona e tutto il
resto però ricordatevi che fare una
bella impressione per quanto riguarda il
look è sempre una buona cosa
iniziamo dalle medie so che tante
ragazzine si iniziano truccare già prima
so che tante ragazzine non si truccano
assolutamente alle medie quindi questo
make up che vi propongo è un make up che
dovete adattare ovviamente a quelle che
sono le vostre preferenze ecco quindi se
ragazzina che sta curando il video e
file e medie
non vuoi truccarti non ti piace
truccarti non è che perché se io faccio
vedere questo make up devi iniziare
truccarti deve essere una scelta tua
devi essere pronta tu a fare questo
passo
come vi dicevo io ho iniziato truccarmi
in terza media ma la mia passione per il
make up è nata prima infatti rubato i
trucchi a mia mamma mi truccavo in casa
ovviamente non mi faceva uscire truccata
tant'è che mi hanno messo i soldi da
parte per comprare il mio primo mascara
di cui andavo fierissima lo metto lì in
bella vista in camera mia mamma dopo due
ore per aveva nascosto
io sapevo i suoi nascondigli quindi
fondata nell'armadio e ho trovato il
mascara che mi aveva sequestrato prima
di parlare del make up
un consiglio che mi sento di dare ai
ragazzi e alle ragazze della vostra età
è quello di detergere bene la pelle di
curare la vostra pelle tanti ragazzi
hanno problemi di acne di impunità di
pelle grassa
quindi è a maggior ragione fondamentale
detergere bene la pelle toglierebbe
tutte le impurità tutto diciamo il sebo
cattiva accumulare sui poli e che poi
insomma fa venire i punti neri
brufoletti eccetera eccetera
questo qui è il make up che mi sento di
consigliarvi per le medie e un make up
molto semplice pulito non non è
esagerato è secondo me adatto a delle
ragazze di quell'età
vi faccio subito vedere che prodotti
utilizzato loro utilizzato questo gel
per le sopracciglia di benefit che si
chiama tim brown che un gel colorato che
va insomma
pettinare le sopracciglia dando un po di
colore eviterei la matita avere
sopracciglia proprio super definita
perché secondo me è un po esagerato per
quanto riguarda la vostra età
fondamentale il correttore io uso questo
qua di nars sulle occhiaie sulle piccole
imperfezioni sui brufoletti lo usate
tranquillamente un pochino di blush che
non guasta mai secondo me down aria
molto fresca molto sbarazzina mascara io
l'ho messo vedete voi insomma come come
preferite ma tante ragazze magari da
fastidi addirittura al mascara quindi
dovete assolutamente vedere voi quello
che preferite e quello che vi fa sentire
a vostro agio
per quanto riguarda le labbra io vi
consiglio un semplicissimo balsamo per
le labbra un burrocacao che va insomma
nutrire le labbra a dare un po di
definizione rendere valorizzare di più
senza appesantirle quindi eviterei
rossetti eviterei gloss eccetera
eccetera
adesso passiamo a due opzioni di
pettinature di acconciature che secondo
me sono perfette per le medie
per quanto riguarda i capelli anche qui
vi consiglio qualcosa di super ordinato
e supersemplice sinceramente per il
primo giorno di scuola eviterei di
lasciare i capelli sciolti
è una questione secondo me anche appunto
di presentazione quindi il cappello
legato è più ordinato da sempre e mette
anche in risalto il vostro viso il primo
look che vi consiglio è una semplice
coda bassa quindi un classico
con un piccolo accorgimento chi mi segue
da un po di tempo
l'avrà già visto in qualche video fate
scivolare l'elastico vedete verso il
basso in modo tale da creare un buco qui
in mezzo dopo di ciò girate dentro
l'elastico con la coda e guardate vuola
guardate che bell effetto che si viene a
creare seconda acconciatura un classico
di sempre
la treccia una bella treccia bassa
pulita ordinata e semplice è secondo me
una delle acconciature più adatte per il
primo giorno di scuola che da subito
quel look da brava ragazza che ci fa
sempre comodo
passiamo alle superiori per comodità ho
tenuto la treccia di prima ma ovviamente
vi farò vedere anche in questo caso
delle pettinature adatte alle superiori
per quanto riguarda il make up non ho
fatto altro che enfatizzare un pelino
quello delle medie sono andata a
definire un periodo di più le
sopracciglia utilizzando una matita per
sopracciglia a punta fine quindi andando
a disegnare però per pelo rendendola
punto più definite dopo di ciò sempre
con un prodotto di benefit questo qua è
un illuminante appunto per l'arcata
delle sopracciglia quindi va a definire
ulteriormente per enfatizzare lo sguardo
utilizzato questa palette di cliomakeup
che ha appunto delle tonalità
sul marrone è anche un news quindi ho
applicato questo qui sulla palpebra
mobile e sono andata a scurire un pelino
l'angolo esterno dell'occhio con questo
marroncino qui quindi niente di troppo
scuro
però comunque all occhio più definito
all occhio più evidenziato sicuramente
di prima senza andare a fare qualcosa di
pesante che lo appesantisca troppo per
l'angolo interno utilizzato questo
ombretto chiaro per appunto aprire un
pelino di più lo sguardo e l'ho
applicato qui dopo di ciò come se fosse
un eyeliner ho utilizzato questa matita
di make up for ever marrone e sono
andata a colorare la rima ciliare
superiore facendo una linea sottile ma
anche può anche essere motivo più spessa
l'importante che poi con un pennellino
l'andate a sfumare bene per non avere
appunto l'effetto riga ma per avere
questo effetto un po sfumato che a me
piace molto soprattutto perché
utilizziamo un colore marrone non un
nero e quindi come nel caso
dell'ombretto intensifica senza creare
l'effetto panda o l'effetto occhio pesto
o l'effetto cleopatra che magari
possiamo utilizzare per andare a ballare
ma non per andare a scuola
dentro l'occhio eviterei di applicare
ulteriormente la matita anche perché a
me piace molto lo sguardo aperto pulito
quindi l'occhio truccato sopra ma sotto
no
e anzi ho utilizzato una matita di
benefit cioè una matita è sì una matita
in gel ai bright pencil che è appunto
color burro e complicata dentro in modo
tale che lo sguardo sia ancora più
aperto
ho fatto anche un pelino di contouring
ho utilizzato questo quali 20 beauty il
colore e moka quindi ho definito un po
lo zigomo un pelino il naso lo rese un
pelino più affusolato e dopo di ciò ho
utilizzato anche l'illuminante che
invece per quanto riguarda il make up
delle medie ho evitato
mi raccomando eviterei l'effetto shine
bright light diamond metterei un perino
magari qua sulla punta del naso un
pelino qui e basta
non abbondiamo ecco per quanto riguarda
le labbra io ho utilizzato questo gloss
di to face the sleep injection che fa
anche un effetto da anche un effetto
rimpolpante e volumizzante ma potete
seconda usare qualsiasi tipo di gloss
anche colorato ma rimarrei su dei toni
news
passiamo alle acconciature anche qui io
opterei per i capelli legati perché come
detto prima sono più ordinati la prima
acconciatura è una semplice coda non la
farei troppo bassa né troppo alta la
farei a metà
luca cosa aggiungerei a questa coda per
renderla un pelino più speciale questo
elastico che io amo l'ho comprato da
chen mhm ma lo potete trovare in altri
negozi insomma si usa abbastanza cosa
fate
ovviamente con l'elastico attorcigliata
intorno alla coda rilasciate insomma
questo fiocchetto in mezzo alla coda
vedete da un bellissimo effetto
ovviamente io ho questo qui giallo che
non è abbinato all'outfit lo potete
ovviamente prendere è di un colore che
stia bene anche con lauti secondo me
un'idea molto carina
lo trovo molto molto particolare è
comunque semplice non troppo elaborato
secondo e ultimo acconciatura il messi
ban lo sto già facendo anche sono uno
specchio spero che venga bene
tirate sui capelli perché dopo
differente uno chignon un putsch e
iniziate a tirare fuori dei sacchettini
vedete così sottili non troppo spessi in
modo tale che di appunto l'effetto
spettinato dopo di ciò con il vostro
elastico andate a fermare il vostro
chignon che potete farlo più o meno
definito con la ciambella o meno
l'effetto finale è questo a me piace
tantissimo perché amo i raccolti però
pensato per la scuola andare con tutti i
capelli tirati tirati da un po troppo
l'effetto ballerine invece così è un
pelino più sbarazzino ma è anche molto
molto fashion molto town
poi visto che durante l'estate ha
tantissime
si schiariscono i capelli le punte mi
piace tantissimo questa acconciatura
perché appunto mette in risalto le punte
più chiare e questo effetto quindi
doppia tonalità secondo me è molto molto
carino
ricapitolando semplicità pulizia quindi
i capelli mi raccomando appena lavati
ordine e sobrietà ecco non cerchiamo di
strafare il primo giorno di scuola ma
anche durante tutto l'anno perché
sappiamo bene che la gente si basa molto
sul nostro aspetto esteriore e quindi ci
vuole un attimo magari a farsi prendere
in antipatia perché è uno è troppo più
truccato degli altri e vestito un po più
eccentrico quindi mi raccomando siate
voi stessi ma cercate ha cercate anche
somma di di contenere il vostro la
vostra esuberanza magari per quando
andate a ballare per quando uscite con
le amiche siamo sempre in una situazione
scolastica dove insomma i professori vi
giudicano come sapete anche per il
vostro abbigliamento
io per prima da ragazzina magari avevo
la pancia di fuori e venivo sgridata è
così dobbiamo adattarci a questo
contesto quindi limitiamo la nostra
esuberanza riguarda abbigliamento è un
make up
spero che questo video vi sia utile mi
raccomando in bocca al lupo per tutti
coloro che inizieranno la scuola a
maggior ragione per chi inizia magari il
percorso delle medie e delle superiori
state tranquilli andrà tutto bene dovete
assolutamente essere voi stessi e mi
raccomando
studiate vi mando un bacione e ci
vediamo al prossimo video ciao
[Musica]